[Music]
exciting laughter she's coming up so -
promise to talk about something boy
like many other speakers I'm very very
happy to be here and it's been an
incredible session just especially today
was a great I mean great fun and in a
way a good sort of take off from the
first two speakers a Peter and Garrett
from a lyft and uber I mean they were
talking about some of the reasons why
economics 101 just doesn't really fit
very well the the ride-sharing zone in
the city and I think it gives you
insights it gives you all sorts of
things but it a lot of supply and demand
competitive equilibrium theory does a
great fit and and I've been arguing for
sometimes I think half of you know that
I feel the same way as true in the Power
Systems area and so I'm gonna go in and
review some of my past work in that area
and and and some new insights and this
is try work with a lot of people because
I'm reviewing a lot of material so
there's my old Illinois a world over
here I I started out working this era
because of I guess we don't have a laser
pointer at home in person who chose an
economist at Illinois he said sort of
brought me into the power area to begin
with and then Peter Berger who is my
reason finish up in Florida who is a
colleague colleague there on a blue
shirts who you know in their string of
graduate students there Huey Chen is now
at NREL with my buddies over there all
right so I'm going to talk about the
irrational agents the power grid is told
by three agents and that's the balancing
Authority put the power economists and
power consumers and I'm going to give
you a crash course on that economics 101
that was referred to by by Peter but in
a dynamic setting and so if you take an
account the fact that power generators
have RAM constrains that sort of thing
and this is really old work so it's
almost embarrassing to present it
because there's a few people have seen
this
you know I don't know you know what when
they were 16 or something I but I feel
like I need to I need to set this stage
and then I went to about the real
efficient outcome is and why the hell
we're not there and I think it's because
of the fact that a misunderstanding
economics so I think if we really did
the economics right the you know the
incredible innovation we saw in
communications could happen in power and
I think that I think that the wrong
price signals the wrong market
structures are the biggest problem okay
all right so this is from the beginning
of this month for California so March
4th 2018 that is a view of the poor
balancing authority the grid operator
today where this yellow here is
renewable energy and so I'll explain
those ok so balancing authority I'm so
many of you saw the bootcamp and sort of
learned about this but you know the the
the u.s. is broken up into little
regions big and small there's a
balancing Authority that helps to manage
the grid to make sure that frequency is
regulated that the flow is between
balance unit areas or you know flow is
as expected I think things like that and
they have an incredibly difficult job in
terms of learning these markets and
balancing things and this again is this
plot it shows the California region a
huge you know
operating region in California and what
they had to face doing this one day
March 4th 2018 50% of the demand was
served by solar at 1 p.m. which is you
know which was a record and look at this
ramp in power so it's going from 6
gigawatts up to 24 and so you know I
took in context that's 18 gigawatts a
big nuclear power plant is
one-and-a-half gigawatts you know you
know a the most thing the biggest new
you know new clean gas such combined
cycle gas generates about a gigawatt and
it's a nightmare trying to ramp them all
up like
and it's a nightmare for these
generators you see sitting around like
this and then beyond for a few hours and
then sit around like this to the next
day I'm just imagine that I mean you you
know you you you've invested a billion
dollars and you're stuck with this
generator and now I'm only allowed to
run it for four hours in a day
it's an insanity you know it's really a
problem they've and and so let me it's
not my talk but the mistake number one
in the power area is the idea the effect
of sunk cost fixed cost a billion
dollars for a generator you spend that
you're stuck with it for forty years all
the money spent on fuel for forty years
might be two billion dollars and this
fixation with variable costs over fixed
cost is mistake number one in the in the
economics and power area and so if we
brought in Williamson in the economics
department here it's a of course I mean
we got books on that that when you have
a a market with huge fixed cost and
lower variable costs competive equal in
theory is very very weak and cosa wrote
about that look we just memoir to to see
how much he cared about that so it's
very difficult it's so anyway yeah
what's that oh yes I think I forgot to
record it yeah I think it was the ramp
yeah I think they had a record ramp
thermal thermal this so good natural gas
generators coal generators that sort of
thing yeah that's right you know a lot
of people think that's thermal like okay
and so yeah that's not a great career
but the fact that 10 gigawatts of
thermal a generation new gas turbine
generators these billion-dollar power
plants so it's maybe that's 10 giant
power plants just needs a few hours it's
incredibly costly well if this was
Florida they'd all be a gigawatt each
and in California it's a bit of a
mismatch so how did make a lot stro
gigawatt yeah I know that's right and
for these you know yeah that's right in
order to be able to cover this
these are peaker plants that are smaller
yeah absolutely yeah that's right
they're really efficient generators
don't like doing that as much
okay and so you know we've many of you
have heard the story of negative prices
you know basically you can have negative
prices for long periods of time during
periods of lots of Sun and and that's a
very strange fact but it's just the fact
that it's very much like chasing the
goose I mean you know people could run
in and and take that power if it because
it's free but by the time they get there
it's gone there's negative prices in
Minnesota all the time why don't they
build a a aluminum manufacturing plant
there it's been negative for years well
as soon as they got there the prices
will go up okay and so and again not
just it's not just the oversee mean the
supply of power from solar that causes
negative prices but you can get because
of these ramps or get price spikes for
you know periods of time and so you know
one of the solutions to this it's been
to come to unbundle the generation
services so I'll have a wrap-up product
and auctions for that and a ramp down
products and you know I I think that's
because you know power economists and
MBAs gotten to the room to companies
market structures and not engineers so a
control engineer knows how to address
these problems and say here are the
products I need and we need a market for
those products but whoever came with a
ramp-up product you know I could have a
market for that I have a market for that
as separate products didn't talk to the
control engineers no that's that's a
problem that's not this talk it's just
another editorial okay so that's the
view that's a view of the balancing
authority they has to deal with these
markets and you can see this is an old
talk I mean based on old talks because I
don't have any crises since 2011 you can
you can see them but this is might one
of my favorites because in Texas in the
winter of this year some generators
froze and it made the prices go up to
the price cap and I always argue that
why would you insulate your generator if
you can make millions of dollars from
getting a generator freeze
what's up this is um
yeah in the I'm just saying there are
two events they they had generate his
fries and breakdown you know and then in
the summer you had a high period and you
had praises go up for about a month they
both stay ahead in real-time markets and
that time there's a price cap of three
thousand dollars a megawatt hour when
it's normally thirteen twenty you know
dollars a megawatt hour and the solution
this problem was to raise the price cap
so now it's six thousand alright so I
want to just make clear that it's true
today and it's still true that many many
power economists are pushing for the
real-time prices and particular
Borenstein who is you know in Berkeley
says that virtually all economists agree
that the California crisis was
exacerbated by the inability of the
demand side to respond to real
artificial shortages this realization
prompted my research on real-time
electricity prices and he says so he
says that all economists agree he's
talked about the power economist sector
not not the broader economic community
and and Frank walk is another person who
heads the economics Institute at
Stanford and he says that you know
active participation in the wholesale
market is essential managing the greater
intermittency of renewable energy and a
demand is able to reduce its consumption
in real time in response to higher
prices is essential
well I want to counter that I want it I
want to convince you all that that isn't
that's that's not true it's not true and
I can't give you a scientific argument
water okay I understand why explain to
you why Frank walleye concern Borenstein
many others believe this but I want to
show you that this is there's problems
with this this the ideal models that
they use okay and I want to remain
friends with them and I would like to
have a friendly debate I'm not trying to
win anything I guess I would and I think
if we think apartment markets will be
more exciting research and more
innovation
that's it might be a different topic I
don't know we'll see to be continued
but I want to do it
what batteries are good well nobody all
disagree about that but it depends what
our goals are okay so I've got to talk
about our goals you know so in the past
I've always argued the issue is
long-term incentives that basically in
fact you know you forced me to do it so
one of the great success stories in the
last few years was and they realized the
problem of large fixed cost and low
variable costs for batteries and so with
FERC order 755 which mandated high
quality of services and and this mileage
payment so payment for how much I
deviated okay it was a mechanism design
hack and at first I thought it was crazy
then I learned it was really effective
because the higher performance brought
prices down and it did create incentives
all these battery companies moved in
with new products well guess what
happened so in the short term there was
this incredible revolution incentives
for new devices lower costs because of
better quality but guess what's
happening now all those battery
companies were tricked
they ran into the PGM territory they
spent their billion dollars and now they
have to have auctions every year for
mileage payments the constant mileage is
the hump the distance tracked up and
down and the CEO not the former CEO
Terry Boston was bragging a few years
ago about how those auction prices are
going to zero so you can get these
incredible like the Chilean deregulation
of power sector it was incredible
success for one year and then and then
the government had to just buy up all
the those businesses I'm thinking long
term okay all right
and out in 95 percent of the electricity
sold in long-term contracts the
underlying absolutely it's a really good
point absolutely so it is absolutely
true that the real-time markets and all
that are a small part of the market
absolutely but it's a huge part of of
thinking right now so it's a huge part
of thinking right now and it's pushing
the way in which we're trying to manage
the grid the New York is trying to redo
their grid and well Audry's implement
who is the the PSC Commissioner wanted
everything to be real time prices
samadhis wants to get water heaters in
there's pressure to use real time for
access to consumers everywhere you look
you'll see real time prices being pushed
and I want to explain why that's not not
a good idea even though it looks good on
economic grounds economic 101 grounds
alright so basically the way things work
today there's a day ahead market and by
the way air caught billions of dollars
came out of the economy during that
crisis so I mean it might be small but
boy it's big there's a day ahead market
you know for basically putting in
resources in a row and there's a
real-time market which is because those
forecasts aren't perfect and I always
think of this as like if this was flight
control that's the jet engine and that's
the flaps in the airplane because in
reality our predictions are pretty much
mean zero so that fine-tuning is up down
up down up down so calling this an
energy market I think was a mistake to
this for the first place okay but I'm
going to focus on this real time market
which this is the wholesale electricity
market but in the end we're gonna be
talking about consumers like prices to
aggregators consumers all right so just
so it's a old work the economics 101
that I want to survey here's an example
of where you take basically look at a
reserve model I've got the generation at
time t minus the demand and I have you
know D of T is the actual demand -
forecast so sort of a deviation market
which is what the real-time market is
and and the
you know the prior work that we did we
the only constraint we put in is is like
the friction that you see it in in it
uber or length that there's a rate at
which you can ramp up and it and just
the little thing like that can reveal a
lot of features and then later work we
had all sorts of constraints that we
wrap up constraints around constraints
and so forth all right and and look at
so a dynamic setting what we're looking
at the discounted total cost expected
cost and and basically there's a
generation for the supplier in a
generation for the consumer
that's the desired generation of the
consumer that's a desired generation of
supplier these are of course equal
because it's only one you know instead
of generators creating power but but by
calling that a constraint and
interesting Lagrange multipliers that's
how you can drive the welfare theorems
of economics all right
so and and basically the first
assumption is is this price taking
assumption the price is exogenous and
and which is maybe reasonable there's a
lot of players ok all right
so you take this constraint oh that's oh
yeah all right so there's two well I'm
sorry there's two welfare functions and
it time is so short it's to welfare
functions right I didn't define let me
define them so for the supplier there's
a price I have to pay for power ok and I
practice that I received from from
selling power I'm sorry and mine is the
cost of generating power so that's very
well to find and for the consumer
there's a a utility function for power
delivered minus the price I had to pay
for that power an example would just be
a piecewise linear model where there's a
value of consumption times the minimum
of what I wanted and what I got a cost
of black out and then the price here
okay so it's fun and this is why control
people love this you take the you take
the constraint that supply equals demand
you relax it by putting a little ranch
multiplier and now any control person
says that's the minimum principle I've
done that and you get really excited and
you get all these beautiful theorems you
get it you get a Lagrangian
decomposition so you get there's a two
separate optimization problems the
supplier optimize of a GS the consumer
optimizes over Gd and if if the the
original problem which is called the
social planets problem has a solution
and no duality gap there's a dual here
that's there's no duality gap which will
be twin two very general conditions you
get all sorts of beautiful things so the
Lagrangian for the the constraint that
supply equals demand is basically the
price which is well-known in a static
setting and Frank wallet says it was
well done to him too and I believe it in
a dynamic setting and you find out the
price is always marginal value not
marginal cost no way a heart cell value
it's as hard constraints on generation
that that make it typically not marginal
cost
all right so also you can show that
under the right initial conditions which
is the optimal Nishal conditions that
the average price is the average
marginal cost and any economist goes
screaming with happiness because
everything's solved you know I mean
everyone solves I mean and if the cost
is convex enough then the revenue
adequacy is okay and all it turns out
you know with transmission constraints
you can imagine that prices are know it
all but they can also can be negative
and they can be bigger than original
value okay and so there's a bibliography
just like a mesh I don't have time to go
through a literature survey all right
I love you anyway
but so doing constraint settings you can
definitely see the prices now marginal
cost I mean it's absolutely alright but
they know it so now I get to one of the
main points and I you know what I've got
seven minutes oh my god
this model of the supplier is reasonable
there's a cost of generation and they
want to make money what about this you
know I did too fast
there's the irrational agents I finally
showed you these two guys that's my car
thing could show and that was me in a
bad day in Illinois what is a value of
power to consumers so remaining five
minutes I want to blow that out of the
water it doesn't make any sense it never
made any sense okay and let's just go
through it so there's a there's a quiz I
made you go through at the bootcamp for
half of you and I'm just gonna go
through really quickly you're gonna take
the quality of life test if somebody
turned off the lights while you were
getting ready for a lecture or pull the
plug in a computer at time T naught you
were happy happy happy
what would you be here if that's angry
you know you'd be this person all right
what what what if what if they unplugged
your fridge or your hot water heater
would you scream you wouldn't know it
and so you get something like this you
know and there's a time constant there
depending the size of the hot water
heater or the fridge and the thing is is
that power can be shifted because of
thermal inertia time constants of algae
and I learned recently time constants of
cows for cow cooling so this is a miss
one mistake that I think has been made
in this literature is that the welfare
function for consumers has to reflect
the quantity of interest and it's not
alright so I'm going to go through some
some illustrations of why this is a big
problem and and then we can stop
so there's a welfare function for clean
water or temperature so but this is
something you might not know if you're
taking a shower you want your
temperature to be in bounds like this
but power consumption is a pulse train
it's four kilowatts zero four four hours
four kilowatts zero four four hours you
couldn't care less about power
pretending that there's a utility
function for power is a mistake it's
utility function on temperature that's
true of most loads okay so that's not a
very rational agent all right so here's
the efficient outcome real fast so first
of all why do price signals would not
work because power is not the right
commodity of interest and you can see it
through an experiment if you take a
bunch of I'm an aggregator I've
contracts with a bunch of consumers so I
act in their interest and I will then
optimize the underfur under their
interest to make sure that their quality
of services and bounds you all know
what's gonna happen if the grid operator
wants this reduction in load and they
use time-of-use pricing I may be you
know P forget that that's just saying
that I'm gonna keep quality of service
and bounds
what's gonna happen is if they increase
the price by 10% during this period what
are they gonna do think about it not to
set one percent not 10% 100 percent it
doesn't matter what are they gonna do
they're gonna pre-cool the fridges and
they end the HVAC they're gonna they're
gonna ramp up the power as much as they
can before they fed and they're gonna
shut off everything as long as they can
so four fridges it might only be half
hour for hot water heaters it could be
the entire event the fact that the
response is it has nothing to the price
just proves the point there's no
connection between well there's 10% or
20% 30% and the response and that shows
that there's a mistake you can't use a
utility function for power in a model of
economic economic s-- okay and so this
is what ends up happening is you get
this huge price spike things go off and
this no matter what you do with with
Tommy's price you know it and and real
time would be worse and it's not
anything to do with what the grid
operator once
and so the problem is that the the
aggregator has no quality of service
promises to the balancing Authority so
wrap this up so what does the efficient
outcome really look like I mean let's
just think about it if I might get
aggregated all right let's just make
sure that air gate has a contract with
the consumers in the balancing Authority
and truly optimizes the social welfare
that's what you do to define efficiency
let's look at that first all right what
what is the efficient outcome look like
and so basically using loads it's known
as demand dispatch I'm really going to
control the Lord's but but making sure
the the constraints are in bounds here's
what you can actually get from those
water heaters fridges basically the
inventory we have today in California
you could take this horrible net load
that you see today in California and you
could pull down that peak by several
gigawatts and you could pull up that
belly by several gigawatts just with
what was it you know a million poles a
half a million water heaters and so
forth now they're predicting that that's
going to double like California's be
electrified so in in 10 years they'll be
at least twice as many hot water heaters
and so forth
and so this is going to come down by six
gigawatts if you do this central plan
Aries optimism optimization problem now
I'm not stolen I'm just saying here's
the central centralized optimal solution
and the consumers don't feel a thing
because they get exactly the quality of
service they want the temperatures
exactly the bounds that they they asked
for it doesn't cost them a cent
all right now in the future you know
when we get calculating in electric
vehicles and all that I I don't believe
it'll all be through demand using low
but you know eventually we could solve
that control problem but the problem is
incentives for getting these things in
place all right
so I'll close with that I'm not going to
show this so honorably Shh and I have
had a string of a dozen papers on how
you can use distributed control to get a
bunch of refrigerators to track a signal
interest I I've ran out of time
so again since scorpy this fred schweppe
and the late 80's and all there's this
passion for competitive equilibrium
theory powers always treated the
commodity of interest that was a mistake
ok and if I'm wrong tell me offline
there's also issues a long-term risk
when you look at competitive equilibrium
theory EDF recognized that in the 80s
and schweppe also recognized that of
course is risk to the great operator
have time for that
and don't forget this I just wanna say
it's one more time I want you all to
burn this into your brains you guys
never see what power looks like you know
fridges are like this too I mean almost
anything that's deferrable the
connection between power and the
commodity you care about is so far away
and that is irrational and so when Bill
Hogan says I wish the agents were more
rational they are it says you have the
wrong utility function alright so anyway
so we need a science for long-term
contracts there's one recent example
here from aside oh yeah an HR you know a
psalm article and we have to live at
risk on longtime skills not just not
just the six months oh no I don't know
if it is yeah I don't know if it is if
they're trying to do it through real
time prices it's a bad thing because no
academics then divide out so I'm talking
about the control so the the market
solution that's being promoted so much
is based on on on auctions that are
going to lead to marginal cost of that
resource
well the marginal cost is zero it goes
up to zero people know that in advance
I'll never get a I'll never get a loan
from a bank to finance my my company so
I'm talking the read batteries are
awesome and we need incentives for
battery companies to get moving and
lower their risk because they need some
some insurance that they could be able
to get in the business and make a profit
that's my point
with prices and claims on that yeah well
III III I wait for that to happen I wait
that's the thing is that I'm constantly
told that somebody solve this problem
and it's just we're just waiting to
implemented so implement it do you get
out MATLAB and run it and see if you can
get this beautiful you know this
beautiful behavior you know can you can
you get that with arrow-debreu I doubt
it I think you need some control
theorists in the room the product is not
a ramp down product and ramp up product
the thing under the bill say the battery
it's going to create a trajectory and
it's a trajectory over that 24 hours
that I want to market for not a product
for that and a product for that that's a
mistake you know and the same with the
real-time prices here the multiplier for
the energy balance constraint it still
looks like a power price high I think
the well I can't believe you asked that
so I didn't pay I didn't pay you to ask
that question
so in fact right there so oh my god so
the question is you know if I went
through a dynamical system model and I
actually computed try to compute the
Allah grants multiply for supply demand
in that case would I be able to get the
efficient outcome and I think the foot I
think the welfare theorems fail are
there's no way you're gonna get that
subtle shifting of these spikes so put
price a common price signal isn't
there's no way I mean this is it's just
I mean I with Stewart trying to do the
algebra just a few weeks ago and you get
these couple difference equations I
don't think they have a solution because
in this ideal world the price is
marginal cost that's not consistent the
differential equations you get for the
aggregator you know for the
yeah I I better my conjecture right now
is it there's no there's no competitive
equilibrium if the welfare function is a
a function of the commodity of interest
say the temperatures doesn't go to
balance the convicts say quadratic cost
on temperature deviation III conjecture
there's no competitive equilibrium and
I'll love it if somebody proves me wrong
zero out of time so you hear that you
have the other boss okay okay well I've
been taking questions okay yeah what we
have some well unplug countries
residential customers examples you show
of course no I'm not I'm not just I'm a
resident or UC berkeley's information
asymmetries initiative Peter if you if
you think this Californians know with
their supercomputers is they know pretty
sure that's gonna be congestion at 2:00
p.m. they need to tell me in advance I
can't recall the Walmart they can't just
wait till 2:00 p.m. so I'm gonna crank
up the parts I'm it's insane to do
things that way it's wrong they need to
give certainty aimed at they again
scheduling as well as we talking about
hold information the suddenly give it a
price and then they have to panic and if
if you get prior information they can
pre-cool which which they do they they
have some properties but you're trying
to make every Walmart into its own